[Music]
vehicles
pretty sure they turned your great spot
into a slurp shop
mindless [ __ ] consumerism wins the
day again
point for the other team huh
huh this is why you don't bring back
fallen warriors
sooner or later they're gonna see
everything they fought for it's turned
to [ __ ]
know anything about any bootlegs from
rainbow cadenza days
like say i don't know uh samurai stuff
you're not like really present oh
that ugly wet face on black yeah
even i know that one old guy comes by
here sometimes wearing this shirt
spends the whole time yakking with his
psycho fan friends
wouldn't happen to know where i could
find him you can find him living back in
the 2020s
but besides that he's out there at the
market
what's he selling organic strawberries
and cream
what do you think he sells ancient
dusty tapes of ancient dusty indie bass
no one's heard of a single one of them
green
thanks
i heard i can get some decent tunes here
what you mean by decent we got cartesian
duelists eurodyne stuff
tainted overlord you need a samurai
kid you even gotta ask
never fade away dancing with my axe
chipping in you name it we got it
silverhand was the one true messiah of
rock
i'd hand them records out like candy if
i could
but a guy's gotta eat
i see i found silverhand's biggest fan
and proud of it today's bitty box
rockers can't even touch him
silverhand had something they couldn't
eat
a silver hand he had that fire kid
fire guy shook the foundations of the
corporal world
he died for his ideals doesn't matter he
was also kind of a terrorist
blaze way down the rebel path
i'm looking for the real deal like say
bootlegs from samurai's first gates
[ __ ] first you have got no idea what
you're asking for
not if you're so so chilled about
don't know how you found out about them
bootlegs but forget it
not gonna give em to the first gunk off
the street
hey i ain't a poser i know everything
there is to know about silver
go on impress me nobody told carrie the
last time they met
[ __ ] this band not your crowd not your
noise
do your own thing yeah sure
i could think of a million conversations
that he had
there were no witnesses
i used to uh come here back when it was
still rainbow cadenza
bootleg sure would make a nice souvenir
of the good old days
cut the scoff you're too young to
remember the first samurai
gigs weren't even out twinkling your
daddy's karoshi's
hey appearances can be deceiving how do
you know this pretty face ain't an
implant
all right how'd samurai's third ever dig
in
johnny my dear expert helped you out be
a quick rundown of samurai trivia
[Music]
yep third gig remember it like it was
yesterday
set my axe on fire then smashed it on
the stage
crowd went wires well
can't wait all day easy
johnny lit up his axe then smashed it
nope knew it who smashes their gear when
they're just starting out
i mean a new one costs eddies
[Music]
johnny please can you stop making my
life harder
my life that's quickly running out
how am i supposed to give a witty
response to that
question it's like kicking the puck a
blind puck
you always freeze up like this
played our third gig at cadenza little
fire broke out
some drunk gonks tried to put it out
with beer
denny's fro got singed wore rigged for a
few weeks
never did get herself any tech
let me think it was a fire
i remember those gonks who tried putting
out with beer
i almost forgot heard johnny started
tossed a cig that was still glowing huh
[ __ ] that said was carrie's no doubt
but hey any troubles
still don't believe you were there but
what the hell
only a real fan can know something like
that
hey anyways gotta educate to you
maybe you'll find something special
under the table
come on have at it
is
it's appreciated take it
spread the good silver handles
you know they say
time is the best teacher used to think
that was true
but look at that guy 60 at least but
still living in 2020
guy's your biggest fan you're not happy
to meet him
blue soccer tower to smithereens and
it's still standing there
just the same don't want people getting
stuck in a rut
stuck in the past want them to change
them and the world
in 60 years something must have changed
you know what changed the damn facade
fresh interface plugs new high fructose
scab syrup
fun fruity flavors a new face of arasaka
same old [ __ ] different packaging
something's changed i mean we can't see
it but
let's change all the same sure now
almost nobody remembers when a person
wasn't just a meat bag full of
second-hand implants
you